official start of summer next weekend
temperatures already going up and up and
up skin care becoming a daily routine
now you have to think about it and not
just talking about sunscreen and lotion
renowned los angeles dermatologist dr
jessica wu says it is also important to
keep using bug spray
i know we're in a desert but las vegas
does still have airborne bugs including
mosquitoes dr wu says it is important to
add bug spray to your morning routine
before you head out the door that's why
this summer your routine before you head
out the door should be after you wash
your face apply lightweight moisturizer
use an spf 3250 and look for the words
broad spectrum so that you're protecting
from uva and uvb rays and
always use bug spray before you head out
the door
she says it's all about prevention so
along with that bug spray dr recommends
some ideas you've heard these before
wear that large pair of sunglasses to
protect your eyes and a wide brimmed hat
when you head outside for long periods
of time